طبيعه الحال هو يوم 14 جانفي
يوما فارقا في حياتنا
كمسؤولين عن ذلك
وكان هنالك نوع من التوتر بحكم ما يجري في
البلاد من احتجاجات
وكان يعني من حيث العمل يوما يكاد يكون
هديه لولا ما قلته
وفي ذلك اليوم
[موسيقى]
علاء بالنسبه لي على الاقل تذكر ثلاثه او
اربعه اشياء ربعمائه او تفيد
في الصبيحه يعني في الساعه 10:30
هاتفني الرئيس زين العابدين بن علي رحمه
الله
وقال لي انزل
حدايا للمكتب
بعد الاشياء وكان في ذلك الوقت بالذات كان
هنالك احتجاج ومظاهره
ومتظاهرين امام مقر وزاره الداخليه
وبلغنا ان ذاك ان كان هناك حمل امامي
لم يكن له علم بهذا الموضوع
ماذا يفعل الرئيس وزير الداخليه انذاك سيد
احمد سريعه
وقال له
لا يجب ان يبقى عليه موقفا لم يكن هنالك
داعي معين
هذا
الهمامي
[موسيقى]
لوزير الداخليه
هذا ما تم فيما بعد هو تمام
همم هذا اخر لقايه يعني عملين
الرئيس ما الذي طلبه منك هل وجهها بامم
معينه بعد بعد حين اتصل
بالوزير الاول
محمد غنوشي محمد الغنوشي
متواصله الجلسه
لزمن غير طويل كنت موجوده ان كنت موجود
جلسه معه وليقول في نهايه امرنا ان نفعل
حاله الطوارئ
وحكم ان ان الدستور يفرض انك في حاله
الطوارئ يكون القياده للقوات
الامن والجيش كلها تحت امره
الرئيس اركان
الجيش انا ذاك
الجنرال رشيد عمار بحيث يتولى الاسراف على
قاعات العمليات في وزاره الداخليه
وفي وزاره الدفاع بطبيعه الحال التي هي
وزاره
وحتى قاعه العمليات بتاع الامن الرياسي
الجمهوريه انذاك للوزير الاول
والخليه الازمه والقياده الامنيه يعني سيد
عمار
بالتحديد ساعه منهج الاولاني حسب مقتضيات
العمل لان كان اليوم يوم الجمعه
وكان قبل يوم الرئيس زين العابدين بن علي
قد حله الحكومه
قرر تكليف السيد محمد غنوشي
لتكوين حكومه الجديده لم يعطيها عنوان
حكومه وحده وطنيه لكن هذه مع اني مجرد
التوجيهاتش اليه في موضوع
بعد بعد الجلسه مع الرئيس رجعت الى مكتبي
وانتهى كما تقولون في الشرق الدوام يعني
حاسه العمل يعني يوم الجمعه تنتهي في بعد
منتصف النهار يعني في الظهر الساعه 1:30
في المساء يعني في العشيه مش في المساء
[موسيقى]
مع متابعه ما يجري انا ذاك
تحدثت انا وبعض الاصدقاء
ان يبدا السيد الوزير الاول محمد الغنوشي
بالاتصال باحزاب المعارضه والمنظمات
الوطنيه
والهياكل
المختلفه التي لها سئلته بالعمل السياسي
مثلا الاتحاد الشغل
الاعراف اتحاد الفلاح
وغير الممثل النواب بعد ثالث ورابعه لو
معناها كان المقترح على رئيس الجمهوريه ان
ياذن بان اتصل الان
برؤسسات تلك الاحزاب بعميد المحامين
برؤساء المنظمات الى اخره واتصلت فعلا بهم
على مدار المساحه حتى حتى الساعه 11:00 او
ال 10 ونصف اخر ما انت حصلت عليه
من بينهم المرحوم احمد ابراهيم
رئيس حزب التجديد يعني الحزب الشيوعي
سابقا مصطفى بن جعفر نجيب الشابي الى اخره
يعني القائمه طويله من اجل تشكيل الوزاره
حتى للتشكيل كيفيه تكوينها الحكومه
الرئيس
المطار او في المطار
وودع عائلتي التي ستذهب الى العمره ولذا
اشرع في الاتصالات
محمد الغنوشي هو الذي يعين لهم الموعد يوم
السبت او يوم الاحد
من غدوه هو الذي سيستدعيهم تباعا او
احيانا الاثنين مع بعضهم او اكثر حسب يعني
الوقت المتاح
فكلمت السيد الوزير الاول انا ذاك
الرئيس قال نساء ووضع العائله الى العمره
ساودع العائله في المطار
يعني على اساس انه سيعود الى مكتبه في
الليل يعني
وبقيت انا كامل
وراجع السيد محمد الغانم ماشي بان اتصلت
بفلان وهو يرحب
بالمبادره هو وعين له موعد الى اخره
دائما ساعات
الى ان سمعته
في احدى التلفازات
في المنزل ان الرئيس قد غادر وهذا امر لم
يكن متوقع ولم يقوله
كل كل معنى شهاده
التونسي
[موسيقى]
الوطني والانابه كانت من الطرف القضاء
العسكري في مستوى الاستئناف التحقيق فيما
جرى وهذا هذه شهاده موجوده يعني ملفها كده
هناك على ايش ممكن ان نتحدث عنها بكل